foreign
[Music]
Deadpool 3 and One Piece season 2 is
ready for shooting are you curious well
this and much more is covered in this
week's Keno check news stay tuned
following the release of I am Groot a
series of short stories starring Baby
Groot director Kirsten Lepore has
expressed interest in another spin-off
but with a different Guardian in the
spotlight I am Groot was distinguished
by a short running time and the
completely animated style of the
individual shorts the fan favorite
dubbed by Vin Diesel was certainly the
main reason for many people to watch the
series is possible successor however
could give him a run for his money
Kirsten lapore who directed the first
two seasons showed interest in further
stories in an interview with
comicbook.com but with a different
Guardian as the protagonist we're
talking about Rocket Raccoon who already
played a central role in the last
Guardians of the Galaxy 3. this could
lead to another spin-off in which the
past of the little raccoon is further
explored likewise Laporte noted that
basically any hero could succeed in the
style of short stories according to the
director however Groot was initially the
perfect choice for this type of series
as he was fully animated in both the
films and series and the transitions
thus feel very authentic we're curious
is to see whether this will work with
other Guardians as well
news from Atlantis after a long wait and
several negative headlines the first
trailer for Aquaman and the lost kingdom
is finally here the footage promises an
epic adventure back in 2018 director
James Wan provided a visually stunning
spectacle with Aquaman which turned out
to be a massive success for DC with
worldwide box office takings of 1.1
billion dollars accordingly Aquaman 2
was eagerly awaited however several
reshoots postponements and debates
surrounding the casting of Amber Heard
dampen the anticipation for the movie
immensely of course the story is about
Arthur Curry AKA Aquaman played by Jason
Momoa he is once again up against Black
Manta played by Yaya Abdul Mateen II the
latter unleashes an ancient power with
the black Trident and is out for revenge
against Aquaman and everything he loves
in order to defeat him Aquaman must join
forces with his brother the Ocean Master
this holds out the prospect of some
conflict as the two were bitter enemies
in the first movie The impressive
footage already suggests plenty of
action to come Aquaman and the lost
kingdom will be released in movie
theaters on December 20th
Deadpool meets Harry Potter according to
an Insider Source Daniel Radcliffe
himself is joining the cast of Deadpool
3. the info comes from Daniel Rickman a
well-known leaker whose disclosures have
often turned out to be true he didn't
want to give any sources of further
details but Daniel Radcliffe is said to
have been cast for a secret role in the
third Deadpool movie in general there
are many talks about the cast of the
action movie it is considered certain
that the Multiverse will play an
essential role which is a great
opportunity for all kinds of crazy
situations and guest appearances just
recently it was revealed that Jennifer
Garner will return as Elektra after more
than 18 years other rumors revolve
around X-Men Halle Berry a storm leave
Schreiber as Sabertooth and an
appearance by Channing Tatum as Gambit
at least most of the big names have been
confirmed for the main cast Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman will star as
Deadpool and Wolverine of course new
characters are being portrayed by
Matthew McFadden and Emma Corin with
corn set to play the main villain there
are also a couple of attorneys from the
prequels include Quran Sony as Defender
Morena Baccarin as Vanessa Leslie Uggams
as Blind Owl Stefan capichek as Colossus
Brianna Hildebrand as negasonic teenage
Warhead and shioli katsuni as Yukio zazi
beats will unfortunately not make a
comeback as domino in Deadpool 3. in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
director Sean Levy spoke about how
important it was to him and lead actor
Ryan Reynolds to particularly get
Wolverine right because Deadpool 3 is
now part of the MCU Levy said he had an
army of the nerdiest Nerds at his
disposal to get all the details of the
iconic comic book costume right he was
all the more pleased with the Positive
reactions there have been to the leaked
set photos featuring Hugh Jackman he
stressed once again that the film is in
no way inferior to its predecessors in
terms of violence in addition Great
Value was set on shooting in real
locations in order to rely as little as
possible on Studio shots in CGI filming
is already halfway finished but sadly it
is currently on Hiatus due to the Acker
strike in Hollywood but the theatrical
release date for Deadpool 3 is thus
entirely uncertain as well it was last
officially set for May 3rd 2024 but has
since vanished from Disney's release
schedule
great news for One Piece season two
while the live-action adaptation of the
anime series continues to dominate the
global Netflix charts preparations for a
sequel are already more advanced than
many would have thought one piece
Creator iichiro Oda announced the good
news in a video via transponder snail
season 2 is officially in the works in
addition it says that the crew of course
urgently needed a doctor this refers to
crew member Tony Tony Chopper half human
half Reindeer the excitement is huge to
see how the cult character will be
implemented in the real stories Marty
adelstein the CEO of Tomorrow Studios
announced in an interview with variety
that production could begin soon fans
can look forward to new episodes within
the next 12 to 18 months according to
Edelstein
a reboot is in sight winesgate will take
on responsibility for a reboot of the
cult classic The Crow from 1994. its
star Bill Skarsgard will assume the lead
role and succeed the late Brandon Lee
Hollywood made sad Cinema history with
the dark Revenge Thriller the crow the
movie is likely to be remembered above
all for the tragic death of lead actor
Brandon Lee the son of Bruce Lee died
during filming when he was wounded by a
prop gun accordingly director Rupert
Sanders is taking on a heavy burden as
he will be directing the reboot the plot
of the movie will be based on the
original story and will be written by
oscar-nominated author Zach Balon Balon
was already in charge of the script for
King Richard which won Will Smith an
Academy Award for best actor in a
leading role the starring role of the
crow is to be played by Bill Skarsgard
this time was able to Prevail over Jason
Momoa and Luke Evans in addition to
Skarsgard singer FKA twigs and actor
Danny Houston will be part of the cast
the film was shot in Prague and Munich
the Thriller tells the story of a man
who rises from the dead to avenge his
and his wife's deaths currently the
release for The Crow reboot is being
considered for next year
martial arts fans listen up iconic
martial arts legend Bruce Lee is
returning in the form of another biopic
this one is to be directed by Ang Lee
and star his son to this day Bruce Lee
is regarded as one of the most important
and best known martial artists of all
time and his films have shaped the
action genre with Enter the Dragon in
1973 he made his big breakthrough in
Hollywood and created a true classic of
the genre the action spectacle was
something completely new at the time and
with its fast-paced fight sequences
exotic settings and charismatic Behavior
it blew the cinemas away resulting in
worldwide box office takings before 400
million dollars however this success
story also had a more tragic side as
Bruce Lee died at the age of just 32 six
days before the film's premiere in Hong
Kong 50 years after his death a new
biopic about Bruce Lee is now being
planned which will focus on the making
of Enter the Dragon producer Lawrence
gray explained in an interview with
collider that the filming of Enter the
Dragon was a moment in which many of the
actors dramas and conflicts came
together thus the movie is supposed to
be a kaleidoscopic journey through Bruce
Lee's life and will bring together
different thematic threads Ang Lee who
is known as an absolute expert in his
field will be responsible for directing
the film Ang Lee directed the martial
arts film Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
and was awarded the Oscar for best
director for his Works Brokeback
Mountain and life of pie his son Mason
is to play the role of Bruce Lee the 33
year old is a popular actor in Taiwan
and was most recently featured in the
acclaimed Thriller limbo currently the
Hollywood strikes are delaying the film
should an agreement be reached in the
near future however production of the
film could begin immediately according
to producer Gray
to wrap it up here's a video
recommendation for all science fiction
fans we have a big preview of all the
best upcoming science fiction movies for
you to enjoy on our Channel we look
forward to reading your opinions in the
comments thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you